is lust wrong no you need the lust
but when does lust become wrong when
it's just haram and it's just there's no
nikah there's no
it's simple the process said just it's a
fine line
two witnesses
and have the lust go ahead enjoy
[Music]
and this is your host gabriel romani
sitting in from ramirez
mashallah and i am joined today by angel
and fayad barakallahu kum salam alaikum
waalikum
[Music]
[Music]
yes episode seven of the intimacy series
and this is
the realest podcast in the dunya the
three muslims masha allah
thank you for having me on again
hey bro as always the
the the viewers asked for it so we gonna
give it to them
they ask do i clap or do i tap listen
we're gonna give you the answers right
here
they shot episode five we were going in
nah bro that was four play they thought
episode six nope oral
menstrual and other photos episode seven
bismillah bro
if you guys think this is gonna be the
episode bro maybe it might not even be
but we'll see
let's see what happens let's see where
it goes yeah so we talked about
uh orozek last time in the last episode
and how important it is specifically for
a female
and for her to climax and
a woman will
[Music]
climax and you will feel it when she
climbs there's a lot of guys they're
like how do i know if my woman climax if
she has an orgasm
it's like a spasm a woman will have a
natural spasm now she can fake it and
we'll talk about that
a little bit but in general it's you
know her breath
starts you know she starts
hyperventilating she gets
all you know moist she starts uh you
know being
sweaty and she starts pulling you
towards her starts moving her hips
basically and then she just climbs
literally it's a climax and you will
feel it
right there's a there's a release that
is associated with that even just a
noise or a sound
or it's kind of like you know what i
mean or she'll even say that i'm coming
and so on you like there's no i don't
think if any man has any understanding
of himself and of his woman will be
confused about whether his woman
climaxed or not
all right that's something very uh clear
so we talked about
yeah we talked about oral sex and how
important is it we said that there's
difference of opinions some people who
are a bit more
i guess you know even though there's no
there's no evidence they will say it's
not
i feel sorry for some of those people
because maybe those are the same people
that their wives
you know ask for divorce or they leave
or they cheat or they masturbate or they
use
toys or all kinds of stuff to please
themselves and their marriages sometimes
go down the drain
because they're not able to be pleased
now keep in mind guys that we're living
in 21st century
and a lot of the issues that we're
dealing with because society has gone
through this
liberal hyper sexualized you know wave
that has come to a sexual revolution
that has come from the 70s even before
that
and the world is is through that and the
muslims are living in the world
and they go through these same issues
they hear it in the school
they see the porn they see the movies
netflix this that
they're living in the west it's
something you can almost not escape
i wanna say this if someone's never
heard or seen anything which is very
doubtful but if someone has never been
exposed to the
problems that the 21st century presents
i think allah has created us men and
women to know how to be intimate just
naturally
naturally if a man and a woman has never
been they've never been
corrupted in their fitrah allah has
created intimacy
for us i believe that they can naturally
be intimidated they can naturally have
intercourse and please each other very
fast without any problems
some of the delay in pleasure the lack
of orgasm
and so on comes from the fact that we've
been conditioned and nurtured
to understand sex in a certain way and
if our partner doesn't do it that way
or falls below the line of expectation
then obviously there will be no pleasure
so a lot of times when we're dealing
with these discussions some are
is quite graphic is because we're trying
to teach the 21st century muslim
who lives in the west or even the east
right now we're living in a global
village
information is accessed everywhere
how to deal like does that mean that if
i've been traumatized or if i've seen
things or if i've done things or if i
committed sin or this or that that i'm
i'm wiped off that's it i should not
have a good sex life anymore i cannot do
certain things that are still
permissible
within it doesn't mean that okay we have
to understand you cannot wipe people off
oh
you know you're a bit this way or that
way let's say you're done no
what i'm saying is that uh people need
to understand what's permissible and
what's not permissible we gave last time
the ruling that in islam
any kind of worship ibaad
has to have a proof everything is haram
unless there's a proof in walmart or
dealings is the other way around
everything is halal unless there's a
proof that it is haram okay this is very
clear
so keeping those things in mind and
keeping in mind what's going on in this
21st century i wish i could say let's
all
purify our hearts and let's just like
clear out and just there's no porn
there's no sex you're walking on the
street
everyone is covered there's no
advertisements there's no clubs there's
no bars there's no
nothing you know you don't see anything
and everything is just conservative
alhamdulillah
okay maybe society with years and
generations would return back to a
uncorrupted natural disposition maybe
where a man and a woman can have
intimacy make love
for two three minutes and both of them
climax properly and it's the best you
know sex they've ever had
but right now you're dealing with a
society that is hurt
is is traumatized hyper sexualized
society everywhere you turn
is sex and
you know psychoanalysis in psychology uh
sigmund freud
which you know the guy is messed up like
he was really uh you know he really had
some issues
and but there are
certain things that he said just by
observation i'm not saying that they can
be verified scientific and that's one of
the issues that we have with freud that
there's a lot of introspection
and a very small simple population and
a lot of his own you know thoughts and
so on
so but he usually used to say that
everything is driven by
sex or the need for sex and
if you look around in the 21st century
you can pretty much say that that is
one big thing he said that everything is
pretty much this
you know uh subconscious drive that
drives us and it's sexual
and he has these stages of development
uh and you know that that
you you kind of go through this pleasure
stages
uh oral anal and so on
and uh he says that if you don't if you
don't
if you don't graduate from these stages
properly then you end up
being in a certain way when you are an
adult
right it's kind of a weird uh theory
it doesn't make sense but when you look
at the issue of hedonism
or satisfying our pleasure if you look
around the world right now in 21st
century everything pretty much
revolves around that pleasures and
desires
and that's why i recorded the hadith of
of when the jibril went and saw jahannam
and he says everyone will enter because
it's surrounded by pleasures and desires
now some people might say okay so you
see that we should have no pleasure no
desires and let's just cut off and just
be monks
and just be people who do not
engage in any pleasure and desire but
then we look at the example the prophet
and the sharia of islam and we say it's
only about the haram that's not allowed
so the halal is allowed pleasure and
desire
in halal and as we said last episode
it's not just allowed it's encouraged
and you get rewarded for it
because allah subhanahu was created in
such a way that he did not
try he did not put us to to to like
make things that are permissible haram
to ourselves
or to deny ourselves the pleasures that
allah has made halal for us
as long as it's in halal he has given us
an option
for everything you want money he's
giving you halal option
you want intimacy he's giving you a
halal option you want more intimacy
you're giving a halal option
everything has a halal option
okay so the muslims have to understand
that because if not that's the problem
in our society
there's this dilemma of can i be a good
muslim yet still
be happy or have things that are you
know pleasurable
and the answer is yes you can as long as
these things are
halal that's how we talked about oral
sex and the importance of that and to
please your wife and to make her climax
and how that helps the relationship and
how that
sets you know the pace in your house and
you know clears the cash and
relaxes her and she behaves in a
different way
and it is important and one point i want
to make here
is that a lot of times when people think
about sex they only think about as
something dirty
and they enjoy that dirty thing no doubt
about it but it's like again a
a dichotomy it's like sex and it's like
it's there but love is something else no
back in the days it used to be called
making love
and i was discussing this with someone
the other day and angel you would you
know
definitely relate to this you know what
i mean uh you know
in the latin tradition okay so like you
know romanian spanish
portuguese italians right we have that
passion and romance and you know it's
like you know
guys are known that they're lovers you
know what i mean
right you got it's just the way it's
something in our culture you know
and and that's something that we you
know we
like i don't know like we grew up with
that like that kind of culture where the
man is romantic he's a
he play he pleases his wife he's very
like and i'm not saying like romantic
like flimsy but he's like you know he's
like
a lover you know what i mean and it was
about making love and there was passion
while it seems that today has been
reduced to just like banging you know
it's just kind of like
there's no passion there's no soul in it
there's no spirit
right so i still believe that the more
we understand that intimacy is
making love as opposed to just you know
just banging
and we're going to talk about the
banging as well because that comes in
sometimes
but you have to have passion you have to
have desire for that woman and she has
to have desire for you and that doesn't
come
other than through love
allah put mawada before rahma
he said that i placed between the two of
you the men and women
this love this passion you know what i
mean that connects you
and mercy right and that's when allah
says
he says and
or his signs that he has created from
his spouses and he has placed this love
between you
right so it's so important to have
passion and love that
fire to you know a man and a woman
looking at each other desiring each
other out of love not just lust
you know like love and lust because
the halal the bond of marriage
is what makes that lust love
so is lost wrong no you need the lust
but when does lust become wrong when
it's just haram and it's just there's no
nikah there's no
it's simple the process said just it's a
fine line
two witnesses
and have the lust go ahead enjoy
so that is something that we have times
the passion is very
very very important and we talked about
foreplay because it builds the passion
we talked about oral sex because it
builds the passion
it leads us to the time of actual
intercourse what happens on the marriage
night this is the big bang this is where
you
you're gonna you know actually do it
right
penetration making love actually this is
the one thing that
you know all the other things are just
to build up to this
one time where you're actually going to
now connect
with your wife with your new wife with
your love
you're going to connect in this
beautiful act
of making love or having sex or intimacy
or whatever you want to call it
intercourse to be more technical
and this is where a lot of men as i said
do make mistakes so
anything to ask or add guys up to before
i get into it
we got 20 20 years 25 minutes
more than enough time to smile all right
so i think i've touched upon this before
in one of my previous episodes that
for many women that night becomes
traumatic because
guys have a distorted view of sex and if
the woman
is virgin and she maybe did not
experience or she wasn't exposed to too
many things
i think i've sent you uh i had the
question that sister wrote right
it was like quite a you know it's very
explicit right but she's like what
should i say
i don't know she's like it's painful you
know and
it's the reality though this is the
reality so the guy
sometimes you just go straight in let's
say he ignores everything we we said he
didn't watch the previous six episodes
right
like he didn't watch the three muslims
into mrs series and he just ignores
everything
and he just goes straight for the kill
try to yeah
yeah is going to hurt okay especially
she's going to bleed
um it's going to be very uh there's
going to be no pleasure
but that pain is a shock
and that's going to be is going to slip
into her subconscious is going to be
associated
uh with her displeasure of you
which translates into problems into the
marriage
oh brother i don't know why my wife
doesn't respect me oh brother she's
always mean to me oh brother she's
always disrespectful
and then when i bring the two together
and i said what's the problem sister
dig dig dig ask ask after half an hour
well you know brother
when he married me he just like did this
and that and i hate him since then i
can't even
stand him to touch me i want to puke
when he likes imagine sister said i want
to puke when he touches me
one sister said i feel like puking only
when he looks at desire with me like you
know when a man looks at a woman he
wants to like be intimate with her
she's like i feel like puking
you know not once like man it's like you
know
people have to understand women are
different if a woman is not ready she's
not able to she's not
attracted to she cannot have intimacy
with you man
she will puke like a woman is not unless
she's a bad woman then she can have
whatever
but a proper woman like she's i feel
like puking when he looks at me why
because the way he approached me
the way he did it is like i was some
kind of
nothing like a you know non-living being
right so that's not the correct way so
if you skipped all the six episodes
you're not doing any foreplay you're not
you know making things moist you're not
getting in there
you know we talked about the clitoral
the orgasm the
g-spot all these things and you're just
going in for the kill
well man you might be hurting her you
might be traumatizing her
and you might be ruining your marriage
so take it easy
some sisters you know i mean this whole
marital rape thing is being thrown out
there you know that
you know i told him no i'm not feeling
and he just pushed himself in
and he just roughed me up and this and
that and he raped me on my marriage
night
all right which was supposed to be the
most beautiful time of your life
we built onto this episode talking about
how you
get into the hotel you feed her some
sweets you pray with her you talk
to her you kiss her you rub her you
this oral sex and now
finally let's say you watched all the
episode this is where you are
the easiest thing to do guys okay is to
uh to basically let's not forget before
you start
the prophet look at look at the detail
bro the prophet saw sallam says put your
right hand on her forehead
okay put your right hand on her forehead
and basically make the dua
okay oh allah
protects you know us from the
yani the shaytan basically and protect
what you will give us
risk from the shaitaan allah
allah protect from shaytan and protect
from the shaytan what
you have given us here's a very
important point why why why this dua
said again he describes it for those who
think that islam doesn't talk about this
thing
look at this my life said if you don't
say that
the shaytan shaytan this is from the
unseen how and this and that
what kind of shaitaan how does it look
this is not this is from the unseen
these are spirits these are gin will
wrap around your penis
all right now you want that you want
company
i don't think you want company man you
know imagine the angels
go away when you're intimate with your
wife the pens are lifted like
everyone shies away you are left alone
with your beautiful wife
to be intimate and enjoy yourself but if
you forget to say this to our don't say
look even there you're supposed to
remember allah to say bismillah
before you enter her okay
there's baraka baraka bro in that
imagine it's a bada
right so you enter your wife the best
position
you know we're talking position is what
we call i think for
to break the virginity to just go and
easy is what's called missionary
position
okay it's the easiest the woman can
control him pull you
okay and you can talk that's the whole
point we talked about
communicate look at each other face to
face
eye to eye you can touch noses touch
foreheads
kiss a lot of kissing a lot of touching
don't just like
become stiff right allah has given you
hands you know touch
have as many points of contact as
possible don't
let your weight on her now okay you're
supposed to use a little bit like you
know
when you do like when you do planks
right you know planking right you can
use your elbows a bit
if you guys don't you know you've had
you you know you obviously
you're a mashallah fitness so planks are
so important for your core strength of
your abdominal
and that's very important developing
your abs and developing your buttocks
okay your squats
for intimacy is very very important okay
good cardio too bro and good cardio
exactly
so if you enter this that's one of the
best position is missionary position
basically you're on top of her she
spreads and you're touching kissing you
know and talking and close
and so on then you go inside slowly
don't just
bam you know go hard because again it
can hurt let her pull you in
talk to her does it feel good are you
okay slowly remove
i forgot to give a disclaimer guys if
there's any kids now would be the
perfect appropriate time to
yo you ever watched that video with uh
the ugandan pastor or no
which one the the why are you gay you
don't know oh yeah
you saw that right yeah how do you get
yeah who is gay
so he uh he said a lot of like uh you
know what gay guys do
and like you know and all that after
that he's like all right guys this is a
parental guidance moment
[Laughter]
yeah at the end i was like bro what is
this guy doing
he's like this is sensitive and now it
would be a perfect time if there's any
kids
to leave so
another position that maybe gives the
woman a bit more control
okay is if she's on top so she can kind
of slide in
as she feels so she uses her knees and
her hips to kind of go down slowly
and if she feels that that's easier for
her that she can control
then maybe that can help and of course
guys don't forget alhamdulillah you know
with the medical advances
pharmaceuticals and all that there's
lubrication right now it's called
personal lube
i usually i highly recommend it on the
marriage night
okay you can get pharmaceutical type
that is clean
and basic i thought you were about to
say that
uh i usually use lube and then you
correct it yourself real quick
i i'll keep that to myself but it's
possible
i mean you know it's possible bro you
never know
advanced positions techniques we're
going to talk about all that in patreon
you know link in description
uh our editor bro if you're editing it
just put it right here
um but with that being said today we're
going to be talking about more like
vanilla
positions right gabriel yeah just uh
vanilla not charcoal
so so so yeah so basically lubrication
is good because it helps
ease things in it makes things moist
let's say if the woman is maybe a little
bit in pain
pain for the woman is not necessarily
pleasure not at the beginning anyway
so basically it means less moisture so
with the lubrication it can make things
easier
and can push things easy and she can
basically
enjoy it a lot more more moisture more
lubrication
easier for her uh to climb so once it's
inside okay
obviously in the first the first time
you're gonna have intercourse
it's not gonna be like the craziest
moves and all that
in terms of you know uh frequency of
trust and speed and so on you want to go
easy first and let her kind of pace you
and tell you okay this is good
yes like that faster and so on she can
tell you can ask her
and you know be a bit sexy and a bit you
know
romantic don't be like okay you like no
like
you know you have to be nice you know uh
and and how you
in how you approach it and uh
you know continue like you remember
right you've already given an orgasm or
two before with oral
now you're you know you're just
basically enjoying the ride
and you know you're talking to each
other and most likely
uh the first night she will not have a
vaginal
uh orgasm it's not that easy for ole
miss some women report having it only
later on
she has to be very comfortable has to be
the right position some women can only
climax in certain positions like for
example only on top
or only from the back okay it depends
each woman is different all right
different it depends
um so and some women report of you know
having no climax as i said from
intercourse it doesn't mean that it's
not pleasurable it is pleasurable
another thing you can do again remember
you have two hands
okay while you are inside and you are
penetrating you can still use your
fingers to stimulate the clitoris
and that is one thing that women report
being a very extreme
orgasm or very pleasurable orgasm is
when you are penetrating and you are
stimulating with your hands
right so you can stimulate the clitoris
for example if you're a missionary
position
you can use your hand to slide in and
just rub the clitoris while you're
penetrating
or from the back it's quite easy because
it's easier to rub
or to wrap your hands around and you
know to rub the clitoris why you are
well you are you rub that micropenis no
no no yeah bro the [ __ ] is basically a
microphone
he's saying while you're doing it use
one hand on the clitoris and then you
can stimulate
her breasts her nipples yes and you can
kiss the other one
okay kiss her or whatever it is that you
want to do i like that you said breast
bro
i had to i gotta keep it forever we have
to bleep you in the last episode
pg-13 pg-13 bro more like
i think it's it's not even pg-13 bro if
there's kids and their parents are okay
they smell love bro i don't i don't see
myself like as a father
being you know shy and
false modesty with my kids i don't want
them knowing this at like five years old
bro
like how western is doing yes but
definitely when
you all know just like you said i think
in one of our preliminary episodes
somebody was asking how do you know when
it's time and you answered it perfectly
bro that
you'll know when it's time they're
coming forward with these things right
so
you know they come out forward just like
that
having worked in schools for so many
years and being a school principal
dealing with thousands of students this
is one of the
common issues sex is always on their
mind
you know i i mean i catch you know like
letters that they write to each other
stuff they put you know because i'm
obviously dealing with the behavior as
well
so i can report as early as grade three
and four that some of the kids start you
know
being heavily involved in these
discussions and sometimes i read some of
the letters that i catch or
notes or you know if i'm doing my
inspection i'm just like whoa you know
this is grade four you know this is
grade three like down by nine ten years
old right
kind of like wow you know that's a lot
of information
so indeed if they're going to public
school or any school even islamic school
i deal with
i do with islamic schools i've never
i've taught in a public school only like
a few times early into my career
i've always been the principal of an
islamic school or dealt with islamic
schools so these are islamic schools
that i'm talking about right so
you can imagine about public schools so
let's yeah let's deal with things
realistic in a realistic manner and
educate our children
in a proper way and you know yeah if
people don't like what we're saying and
obviously they can they don't have to
watch inshallah but
i think i think we're adding a lot of
value uh to
to to the ummah uh by this
inshallah and uh yeah alhamdulillah
anything you guys want to add
there was one topic that we should cover
before we let these guys go
but do you have anything that i don't
know yeah
if you're with your girl with your wife
and you are engaging in sex
something that is really really
powerful for the guy to do to a girl
is to kiss on her neck and then
basically like you're kind of like
biting her earlobe
and like i guess not breathing not like
blowing on her ear but like
that's you know like when you when
you're exhaling like very lightly
well like i don't know why but women
women love that
indeed yeah that part is very erotic for
women the
neck and the ear and behind the ear but
again you have to like
test you know because some women get
ticklish and the way you do it with the
beard and all that women like the beard
by the way surprise they really love it
but you gotta just kind of test it and
slowly some women even though they like
it
and it's pleasurable they're just not
comfortable with it
so just because if she kind of pushes
away the first time or a few times
doesn't mean she doesn't like it that's
why it's very important to communicate
right it's very important for her to
know that she's
safe with you and it's okay for her to
tell you how she feels and what she
likes
because what happens is a lot of women
report that they're not comfortable with
their guy
to tell them what they like because they
feel the guy is going to think they're
dirty or they're bad
right and you know that's why a lot of
them
don't get satisfied because the guy
doesn't understand what they want
they fake orgasm and then they end up
you know
finishing themselves right so it's
important for the man
to take lead again to let the woman know
that you're safe with me
there's no judgment here be comfortable
tell me what you want i will do it for
you okay that's what i always say
you know i i just i'm going to release
an episode soon inshallah about the
importance of the woman to serve the man
in the house
right but i believe this is the one area
where the man
needs to really service the woman and
servers when it comes to intimacy
you know what i mean like it really
needs to to be done
properly right so let her feel
comfortable
and go ahead and let her enjoy let her
talk let her express
what she likes and what she doesn't like
so you can
you know take care of these things so
there's many techniques
uh that can be developed i just want to
mention something uh angel you you
touched upon last time the kegel
exercises
you know and how important they are for
both men and women you you can also find
them as pc exercises or pubic oxical
muscle exercises for under men
and basically their contraction of the
of the uh the muscle that's between your
testicles
and your anus yeah and that's very
important
it's very important for the strength of
the erection
for the delay of the ejaculation and as
angel said for dry
orgasm which maybe we can discuss later
but as well as the quality of the orgasm
you know it's very really really affects
the quality of the internet and it even
it gives you
longer lasting you know intercourse
so that is very very uh important to
increase and to stimulate and to make
the quality of intimacy
uh you know much better right
so i think we've covered that do you
want to get into some positions or
no no no next episode next episode we'll
talk about the next episode we'll also
talk about the
the exercises one thing that obviously
me and angela
you we all we already know but for all
the viewers they don't know
so we'll just act like we don't know for
purposes of that
but what are the rulings on condoms
birth control you know all of these
extra
physical interventions contraceptives
okay so again obviously like uh
with everything there's some difference
of opinion why you have to understand
why there's difference of opinion
because at the time of the process there
were certain
things that were available or certain
things that were done
and then scholars the way they people
see things differently right
so for example what was allowed at the
time of the sahaba that they were pull
out
okay so the processing would allow them
to pull out so when you're about to
ejaculate
you can pull out and not ejaculate
inside the vagina
right so that is a contraceptive measure
or technique
from this evidence
people make what's called in sharia
chaos or analogy
so they say okay that's a form of
consciousness that they had at that time
they didn't have anything else
so hence other forms are allowed i.e
condoms and this
and that right so our condoms in general
accepted by the ulama today yes they are
okay
contraceptives as you know the pill
is it accepted in general it is
personally i just believe there's too
many side effects
and it can affect fertility and other
issues because it deals with
hormones okay balancing and embellishing
hormones
and that is basically messing with your
with your body
and i don't i would recommend people use
other contraceptive measures in the end
no doubt that it is the god of allah if
you're gonna have a child or not i know
so many people
trying so hard and there's nothing wrong
with them and they just can't get it
and there's one brother one sheikh he's
a sheikh and he says
even if i look at my wife she's going to
get pregnant he's i just look at her and
she
go martial he's got like nine kids
already masha'allah and he's like every
time he's like i don't want i don't know
what to do anyway every time i you know
sleep with her she gets pregnant
he gets pregnant gets pregnant you know
uh so surprise it depends
even that is risk and color but
family planning this and that i
personally don't think
that is something i know a lot of people
not like that
but i don't see any evidence for that in
islam like you know the whole family
planning it's a very western concept
now you have to be smart though and how
to go about that
but if you believe in allah i believe
that the best contraceptive
measure is just pulling out
or today with the uh the amount of
technology that we have you can as i
said pretty much
map out or you know those five days
where she's
fertile or she can get pregnant and
don't ejaculate at that time inside of
her
while the rest of the time it's you can
just go ahead and just enjoy
so there's applications because the
woman is like masha'allah you know
they're very very scheduled okay pretty
much
they kind of can pinpoint when they have
their cycle
right so usually the female cycle is
about 28 days 29 days
and out of those days five to seven days
take
uh plus or minus will be the the actual
uh
menstruation so it's quite easy you have
a lot of advanced applications
that you know can help you you can check
the temperature
okay one of the one of the
signs of ovulation is higher temperature
increased moisture again
moisture and increased desires women are
very
very have a lot high desire because
while this allah created him
it's for procreation it's for having
child look at that that's just the
evidence that
you know it's like a woman wants to be
intimate especially when she ovulates
she's extremely extremely in heat what
they call in heat you know
and that is the best sometimes the best
uh intimacy
you know it's amazing how how the
woman's body is finally if
a person studies the female body and
understands it it's just
amazing you know how allah created you
know subhanallah
and that goes without saying stuff like
you know hysterectomy
vasectomy oh yeah guys
this is this is again i'm not going to
give a thought though here but
you know what i'm saying a lot of
creativity
you're taking that purpose away i don't
care if it's reversible like why would
you do that right this is a very western
thing this is a
very um liberal type of mindset you know
we're going to run out of shortage we
have a
population problem we can't have too
many kids no allah will provide
all the risks comes from allah anyway
bro every time
i got married every time i had a child
allah just brought things man like you
can't imagine you know
and he will provide from you from a
place you don't even know but
but you need to believe in that if
you're just like
always panicking and you don't know you
know no
if you believe then it comes if you
don't believe
it's not going to come man it's like the
power of positivity you know
it's like you got to really feel it
right if allah subhana tal if you
believe in allah
as he says in the hadith i am as you
think of me
if you think good it's for you if you
think bad it's for you
right look at that subhanallah how allah
has blessed us
have positive thoughts and be positive
it will come to you what is it what are
the western law of attraction right
like right kind of like that right but
this is the divine law
of risk and barakah you know i mean that
allah
has given us you think positive you stay
positive you believe in allah
allah will give you without a doubt man
you know we provide for you
and for them so in another verse
we provide for them and for you so
no doubt about that
all right my guy angel the prince of
intimacy
do you have anything to say because i
know the king of intimacy today is on my
head
why am i the you just thought bro cause
you can't be the king but if romney's
the king of intimacy
he's he's the most knowledgeable amongst
all three of us
amongst our fans i don't have
what's to say i mean listen i have a lot
like in terms of
what i want to say but like should i say
it no yeah
probably not that's why we're going to
do the painting man we want to get real
with this we want to talk about
at least two episodes that we're
definitely gonna put on patreon
exclusives because again
this is too real for youtube this is too
real for the politically correct
average viewer that tunes in nothing
personal
but again it's priceless advice
you know will save your marriage so if
you guys like what you see
become a patron if not also become a
patron if you want to support us
but if you just don't vibe with us then
why are you even watching this video the
fact that they
they made it this far means they they
vibe with their content right so
it goes to show for something but with
that being said guys may allah bless you
all tune in next time salaam alaykum
[Music]
[Music]
um